[Music]
all right john well in other news
tonight a second procession was held
this afternoon as trooper micah mae's
body was escorted from the coroner's
office to the funeral home
members of the las vegas community made
sure to pay tribute as the procession
drove by
victoria saha was there she joins us
with more
the community continues to show their
support for fallen trooper micah may
there were tears from complete strangers
as they watched his body being escorted
here
into the funeral home nevada highway
patrol and several surrounding law
enforcement agencies continued to stand
by their fallen brother
in a procession they lined up to escort
trooper micah mae's body from the
coroner's office
to palm mortary downtown by the funeral
home dozens of community members of all
ages gathered to salute trooper may
while waving the american flag as the
hearse pulled in
amongst the crowd were other law
enforcement families grieving together
these men and women put their life on
the line every day for us
and it's the least we can do to come out
and wave and flag and give our
condolences and
well wishes for trooper may and his
family trooper may was severely injured
on tuesday while on the job
he was laying down spike strips to stop
an alleged carjacker
on the i-15 southbound who then hit
trooper may
he was flown to umc and died on thursday
we are told trooper may's funeral will
be held on friday but before then there
will be a candlelight vigil
at the police memorial park on tuesday
at 6 pm that's in the northwest valley
victoria saha 8 news now